Kashmir…a paradise that draws visitors from
all over the world.
But, ever since a major terror attack and
strikes by India and Pakistan, they've stayed
away - crippling the region’s key tourism
industry.
Mohammad Shafi has been ferrying people across
Srinagar's famous Dal Lake in his shikhara,
a typical Kashmiri boat, since he was a young
boy.
The recent turmoil has scared away his clients
and decimated his earnings.
"There are about 4,000 boat owners here.
They’ve all lost their business.
It’s a terrible situation."
Shafi and his friends have seen their income
wax and wane over the years - in line with
the militant attacks, protests and crackdowns
that periodically inflame tensions in the
Indian-held parts of the region.
"I don’t know what the problems between
India and Pakistan are…Kashmir is passed
like a football between the two.
It’s just used politically."
It's a sentiment shared by many on the streets
of Srinagar in Indian-administered Kashmir.
Soldiers are everywhere.
The recent war games between India and Pakistan
have added to the sense of unease.
No one was willing to speak out on camera.
"While tensions between India and Pakistan
are winding down after last week’s aerial
strikes, a climate of fear prevails in the
heavily militarized Kashmir Valley.
Here, in downtown Srinagar, shops and businesses
have opened today after days of intermittent
strikes and shutdowns, causing major disruptions
to daily life."
Riyaz Wani's first thought was to stock up
on rice and fuel when tensions erupted over
Kashmir last week.
He’s been through decades of shutdowns and
curfews - and even started his own kitchen
garden in his backyard to prepare for an emergency.
But, the father of two was terrified for his
family when India and Pakistan engaged in
retaliatory aerial strikes last week - just
a few hundred kilometers from here - putting
the entire region on edge.
"Those days were very scary for us.
Jets thundered overhead.
We heard the news that one or two jets were
brought down.
People who got killed .. maybe the two countries
will talk now.
That will be better for every one."
The conflict in Kashmir has dragged on for
decades.
For people here, peace remains elusive in
this beautiful but cursed Himalayan valley
that both nations claim.